the helicopter hovered over the back
streets of manhattan to the untrained
eye it would look like any commercial or
news helicopter the kind of thing that
might catch your attention for a moment
and then leave just as quickly as your
mind wanders over to wondering what
you'll have for dinner nobody would know
from a mere glance that mobile task
force iota 5 were inside a four-man team
on a dangerous mission this has always
been the greatest power of the scp
foundation hiding in plain sight using
the mundane as a cloak to go unnoticed
but this time the monster they were
hunting was capable of doing the exact
same thing and for the personnel of the
foundation this ability is an
affectation a learned and adopted skill
for
scp-247
this ability that it employs to deadly
effect comes as naturally as breathing
air the helicopter was monitoring local
police scanners and phone activity as
well as receiving direct radio orders
from command back at a classified
containment site the latest intel was
incoherent horrified screaming over the
phone traced back to a nearby alleyway
someone had seen something horrifying
this was iota 5's cue to intervene they
rappelled down from the helicopter onto
the roof of a nearby tenement building
clad in thick tactical armor
anti-mimetic scramble goggles dan inject
im injection rifles loaded with 10 cc
s10 syringe darts each one carrying an
immobilizing payload of potent
fast-acting xylazine and high-powered
conventional weaponry in case of
emergencies if anyone in the world was
capable of tracking securing and
containing
scp-247 it was these four operatives and
yet by the end of today's mission one of
them would be dead but they didn't know
that yet like all good mtf members they
had tunnel vision for the mission at
hand they used a fire escape ladder on
the side of the building to reach the
bottom of the alleyway quickly there
they came upon a gruesome sight the
aftermath of an attack on the ground a
dead body with what looked like claw
marks all over it iota 5 found another
civilian
half mad with confusion and terror
hiding behind a nearby dumpster she just
kept shaking and repeating but she was
so little over and over again one member
of the task force corporal rico elected
to stay behind and secure the area while
foundation cleanup teams zeroed in to
sweep the scene and provide amnesics to
witnesses the remaining three continued
the high stakes chase on foot their eyes
in the sky radioed in stay frosty iota
we've got unusual incident reports from
an apartment building a quarter click
north of your position potential
fatalities 247 is an extremely hostile
state engage with caution over the trio
engage quickly running towards the
source of the disturbance at breakneck
speeds they knew they were getting
closer when they heard the shrieking and
the deep guttural growls that low primal
rumbling of a true apex predator already
this containment breach was turning out
to be a horrific mess it was going to be
a nightmare for the higher-ups at the
clean up and misinformation departments
to handle paying to repair inexplicable
property damage providing amnesics to
tens if not hundreds of traumatized
witnesses creating plausible cover
stories for upwards of at least 10 dead
new yorkers but even all that mass would
have to wait until the creature was
actually captured and contained once
more which would be an ordeal unto
itself they found
scp-247's access point into the building
a wooden door torn to splinters by huge
claws and fangs iota 5 charged inside
injection rifles at the ready only to
find carnage in the hallway three more
bodies with deep claw marks cutting into
their flesh it was a harrowing sight but
the team didn't have time to waste
processing it they needed to stop 247
before killed again
and again
and again the team followed the trail of
blood and the claw marks carved into the
ground where 247 had passed after
killing the three people in the hallway
it destroyed another door and gained
access to a nearby stairwell the blood
continued up the steps iota 5 pursued
the next splintered door clawed and
bashed off its hinges led them further
they could hear the growling again
distant but clearly audible they were
close there were another two attacked
corpses in the hallway previous corpses
had been partially or even entirely
eaten these two had just been clawed to
death defensive kills they'd back the
beast into a corner and now it was
panicking slaughtering anything it
perceived as an interference they
pressed on now this was the end game
soon they found the final busted door
this one led into one of the building's
private apartments there'd be no other
way out from here 247 was trapped the
three members of iota 5 shouldered their
injection rifles and crept inside full
stealth mode something about the
apartment was haunting it betrayed all
the signs of belonging to a young single
mother and her only son this was
confirmed when they found the dead body
of the mother in the living room eyes
glassy and throat clawed out with one
feral strike they could hear something
else in the apartment too a soft gentle
cooing too human to be anything else
they followed the noise until they
reached the child's bedroom what they
saw there caused even the most hardened
member of the trio to break out in a
cold sweat
this was the one thing they didn't want
to happen the child utterly oblivious to
the atrocities that had unfolded in this
building to even the death of his own
mother was sitting in his bedroom
petting a kitten it was the sweetest
little cat you've ever seen a fluffy
harmless creature with an orange stripe
coat this is the dreaded scp-247
the child just kept repeating good kitty
good kitty while petting her
scp-247 purred and rolled around
playfully to the untrained eye would
seem that a kitty like this couldn't
hurt a fly but that's where you couldn't
be more wrong iota 5 stared at this
display in a state of nerve shredding
terror thinking fast trying to calculate
their next move ah one adorable little
cat
one of the iota 5 members found
themselves blurting out it was clear
that 247's effects were starting to have
an impact on even these hardened
soldiers and they needed to act quickly
they could fire a tranquilizer dart
right here right now but in the ensuing
panic
scp-247 would almost definitely lash out
and maul the child it wasn't a risk that
they could take but time was already
running out 247 would only allow the
child to play for so long before
something terrible happened it was an
inevitable part of
scp-247's process that's when private
kowalski one of the remaining members of
iota 5 stepped forward he was about to
do the only thing he could do knowing
that it would cost him his life as he
took his final action the foundation
credo looped once more through his head
we die
in the dark so that others can live in
the light fighting against the urge to
rush forward and start petting the cat
he instead lunged forward and struck the
cat with his foot immediately it turned
and pounced knocking kowalski against
the wall with terrifying force it gave
the most ferocious growls as it tore
into the screaming kowalski eviscerating
his abdomen the child screamed and
retreated into the opposite corner of
the room kowalski was done for but now
his teammates had a clear shot they
secured 247 in their sights and unloaded
several darts into its flank sedating it
with their powerful tranquilizers soon
after it gave a lethargic growl and
collapsed onto the ground an evac and
containment team were already on the way
along with the cleaners many had died
that day but at least
scp-247 would be brought back into
containment preventing further bloodshed
kowalski would be given a posthumous
medal of bravery for his selfless
actions in the line of duty as well as a
generous stipend to his grieving family
by this point you're probably wondering
how can a harmless kitten cause so much
carnage mayhem and despair the answer is
simple it's not a kitten at all it's a
fully grown female bengal tiger nine
feet and four hundred pounds of pure
muscle with four inch claws four inch
canines and an inbuilt killer instinct
but due to an anomalous memetic effect
247 can only ever be perceived as a
sweet tiny house cat but even worse due
to its additional cognitohazardous
properties almost everyone who sees 247
is compelled to approach and begin
dotting and fawning over it and that's
exactly how it gets its prey its memetic
properties are actually so flawless that
regardless of foundation countermeasures
it has never been perceived as anything
other than a kitten it's actually only
through forensic analysis into things
like bite and claw marks left on victims
measurements of weight and abnormal
water displacement in aqueous
environments that we can tell it's
really a tiger at all for a brief period
scp-148
a metal that seems to counteract cognito
hazards and mind-warping anomalies was
used in the containment of this
euclid-class creature but these measures
were abandoned after scp-148 proved to
have a negative impact on nearby
foundation staff after prolonged
exposure now strict protocols of
surveillance and distancing are required
to prevent hapless foundation staff
members from being lured into their doom
by 247. the head researcher on the
scp-247 case wanted to conduct a series
of experiments on scp-247
hoping to find out more about the
interplay of its unique traits with
other members of the animal kingdom two
control animals were brought in to
represent the duality of scp-247
control a was a yellow kitten roughly
matching 247's apparent shape and size
control b was a fully grown bengal tiger
representing 247's actual shape and size
a mixed breed cat chasing terrier was
brought in for the first test it
immediately followed control a around
barking wildly until it retreated up a
tree
unsurprisingly it fled in terror from
control b cowering in the corner control
b paid no mind to the dog perhaps
considering it beneath its attention
even as prey with
scp-247 the dog initially ran towards it
barking until it was only five meters
away at this point 247 let out an
irritated mulling noise and the dog fled
to the corner in terror suddenly aware
of its true nature for test number two a
male tabby kitten was brought in as
expected it simply played with control a
and was terrified of control b in the
first part of the test with 247 the
anomalous attributes of the creature led
to some surreal mind-bending footage at
multiple points 247 picked up the other
kitten as an adult female tiger might do
with a cub and lifted it higher than 247
seemed to be capable of it was like
watching a glitch in real time in the
second part of the test the kitten
immediately fled in terror suggesting
247 can control how it's perceived next
came a deer prayed typical of a bengal
tiger
neither control b nor 247 were fed for
three days prior to this experiment and
both killed and ate the deer however
curiously 247 killed the deer with a
single merciful bite to the neck before
eating compared to its more brutal
methods with human targets and when this
experiment was repeated with 247 after
it hadn't been starved it showed little
interest in the deer until it became
hungry again suggesting it inherently
prefers human or human-like prey this
theory was further reinforced during
tests with a chimpanzee the chimp fell
under 247's cognitohazardous spell and
began to pet it seven minutes later 247
attacked and brutally devoured the chimp
as it would its human prey but strangely
the most frightening result of all came
when scp-247 was paired with an adult
male bengal tiger they engaged in
standard mating behavior which later led
to the duo reproducing a new creature
designated scp-247-1
which had all the anomalous traits of
scp-247
but the frightening realizations don't
stop there studies into genetic material
provided by scp-247 show slight
deviation from a typical bengal tiger's
genotype suggesting contamination from
another creature that mated with one of
its non-anomalous tiger parents for
context tiger broods have an average of
three cubs but can have as many as seven
a common practice given how tiger cubs
are vulnerable to cannibalism from rival
adult males looking to court the females
this leads to only one frightening
conclusion there could be more creatures
just like
scp-247 out there apex predators that
seem to the untrained eye like cute
harmless kittens they could be anywhere
and if they're close enough to each
other or other non-anomalous tigers they
could breed even further becoming the
scariest invasive urban species you've
ever seen because after all we know what
their preferred prey is now
so the next time you see a cute little
orange tabby cat and feel the instinct
to pet it take a second to think about
it it may be the last thing you ever do
now go check out scp-45
swinegod at
scp-2845 alien god crash lands on earth
the deer for more animalistic scps
that'll really get inside your head